see
he spoke at barnes and noble booksellers
in washington d.c
this is about 50 minutes
thank you very much
it's a pleasure to be here
let's see
there i guess that'll work
as you can tell from the titles of my
books
i like to
write about secret subjects
preferably very challenging subjects
that have consequences for society
i might be perverse because if if the
subject is too easy i don't want to do
it
and this sometimes gets me into trouble
when i did a book called moscow station
i revealed that a kgb archivist
had defected to the fbi usually they'd
affected the cia but this person wanted
to defect to the fbi and i knew that he
was safe he was in the united states
and
nevertheless i heard from inside the fbi
that they'd opened a leak investigation
and that they're going to send agents
out to my house to try to interview me
so i went through in my mind how i would
greet them i would offer them coffee i
would smoosh them and i would try to
develop them as sources well
i having done several books on the fbi
and
covered the fbi at the washington post
wall street journal boston herald
thought that i knew what fbi agents
looked like which of course is silly but
nevertheless a few days later
there was a ring in my bell
in potomac maryland which is a very
quiet place very few people ring the
bell i opened the door and there were
these two very intense looking young men
with narrow ties and white shirts and i
said well where have you been i've been
expecting you come on in
and they looked at me a little strangely
a little scared maybe and they held out
these pamphlets the watchtower
you might have
thought that i planned the
individual who ran across the white
house lawn to get into the white house
to
get publicity for my book
that's not true but on the other hand in
my book i did predict a lot of
the
scandals that we see now
based on the corner cutting and laxness
of the secret service it's not the
agents
uh who are actually brave and dedicated
and will take a bullet for the president
it's rather the management that has
created a culture
that rewards agents for keeping their
mouths shut
and perpetrating the myth that the
secret service is invincible
and on the other hand punishes agents
who point out deficiencies who point out
problems who even
point out
potential threats
but a major focus of the book is
what agents see behind the scenes
because
they really get to know the real
character of our leaders and that can be
pretty shocking for example
hillary clinton is so nasty to agents
who protect her
that being assigned to her detail is
actually considered a form of punishment
it is the worst assignment in the secret
service
and yet here's this woman who claims to
be compassionate care about little
people she's going to be a champion of
the middle class and yet behind the
scenes she treats those very same people
with contempt
what does that tell you about her
character and how we should choose our
presidents
do we choose them on
how well they smile on tv
uh what they promised which often they
were neg on
or do we choose them on
the same criteria that we use in the
rest of our lives when we choose a
friend we choose a new employee
anybody in our lives we
choose them based on their character we
would never
associate it with someone who treated
uh people who helped them
with with nastiness and with contempt
and we try and we treat them and we
select them on on track record what have
they actually done what what are they
accomplished or what have they what are
they not accomplished and so that's why
you learn a lot in this book about
how we should be choosing our presidents
it is a totally
apolitical book
the book says that
uh president obama and michelle obama
treat their agents with respect and
consideration they'll offer they'll
invite them to dinner
on the other hand agents have been
dismayed to overhear michelle obama urge
her husband to be more aggressive in
attacking republicans and siding with
blacks in racial controversies
the book reveals that
joe biden
first of all likes to skinny dip which
offends female secret service agents
this occurs both at his home
at the vice president's residence
residence in washington and also his
home in wilmington delaware
more seriously when biden goes back to
wilmington which he does several times a
week and that's another issue
he will
order agents to keep
the military aid with the nuclear
football at least a mile behind in the
motorcade
because he wants to have this image of
the regular joe he's a man of the people
so he doesn't want to have a big
motorcade but meanwhile if president
obama were taken out we would be totally
defenseless against a nuclear attack
because there would not be time for
uh the military aid with the football to
catch up with biden so that he could
unleash a retaliatory strike
on top of all that
uh
it has cost we the taxpayers a million
dollars
for
biden's trips on air force 2 back and
forth to wilmington you know it's one
thing to go back and forth a few times a
year to your home but he has a vice
president's residence in washington that
we pay for including five navy stewards
who
take care of every need including making
pastries every night
and
biden treats
air force 2 like his personal taxi
sometimes he'll even go back and forth
twice in one day sometimes he'll even
go back just to play golf with obama and
then go back to wilmington and the cost
has been a million dollars since
biden took office and at the same time
budden claims to be the sheriff is going
to reduce government costs so this is
the hypocrisy that that goes on that you
see
in in the book uh the first family
detail
um in contrast uh president president
reagan was
one of the nicest presidents he would
spend time schmoozing with agents
uh he would whenever he went into air
force one go into the cockpit and greet
the pilots he would remember their kids
names uh whereas jimmy carter did that
only once in his whole four year term
jimmy carter was another phony he would
pretend to be this populist good old boy
peanut farmer man of the people and yet
he told his agents he didn't want them
to say hello to him in the morning on
the way to the oval office apparently it
was just too much bother to say hello
back to another human being
he would pretend to carry his own
luggage in front of the cameras but as
soon as the cameras were gone he would
give the luggage to aids to carry or he
would
or the luggage would actually be empty
sometimes he would come into the oval
office at five in the morning
and tell the press office to tell the
press
that he was in
there working hard for the american
people in the oval office at 5 00 a.m
but
he would fall asleep on the sofa and
secret service agents would see him doze
off
so
these are
character traits that aren't always
obvious to the public they're they're
secret in many cases but when we do know
about them we we need to pay attention
um
reagan
uh
one day was going into the elevator at
the residence
and an aide came up to him and told them
that
donna
rice's affair with gary hart who was
running for president was about to be in
the paper the next day
and reagan said well boys will be boris
but then he went up in the elevator with
his agent and as he was getting out he
said to the agent but boys will not be
president
after reagan was diagnosed with
alzheimer's he said to an agent well
there must be some positive side to this
maybe i'll meet a new friend every day
so that was
the great optimism of of president
reagan
the book reveals that
the reason that john hinckley was able
to shoot
president reagan is that the reagan
white house staff
overruled the secret service to let
spectators within 15 feet of of reagan
as he came out of the washington hilton
totally unscreened
and the secret service did not want that
but they caved spinelessly to what the
secret to what the reagan white house
wanted
so ironically it was reagan's own staff
that
really caused the assassination attempt
and this has never come out before it's
confirmed on the record both by the
agent who was assigned to teach what
they call the reagan attempt at the
secret service training facility and
also by
peter wallison who did a report for the
treasury department when he was
a general counsel the secret service was
then within
treasury
the report never said that it was
reagan's white house staff that was
responsible for this
wallace and later became white house
counsel under reagan and he confirmed on
the record as well that that is exactly
what happened
going back uh lyndon johnson was
uh
totally out of control
of course back then the press never
reported any of this
he would sit on the toilet and defecate
in front of aids as he's as he was being
briefed he would hold a press conference
at his ranch in texas
and
urinate in front of reporters including
female reporters
when he went into air force one he had
this routine
of immediately stripping naked as soon
as he got in the airplane even with his
own daughters and his wife there in the
airplane
uh one day when he was vice president
johnson was late for an appointment with
jfk he was being driven by the secret
service from the capitol to the white
house at about 5 p.m it was rush hour
and he was late and so he
told the secret service agent who was
driving to drive up on the sidewalk get
there faster the agent of course refused
the sidewalk was full of pedestrians
johnson took a newspaper and hit the
agent on the head and said you're fired
this is the kind of thing that went on
every day
one agent said if this guy were not
president he would be in a mental
hospital and really was true and yet we
entrusted our country and the lives of
uh our military who went into vietnam
under his direction
uh to to this guy who uh who was uh
really a maniac
um and so when you really peel back the
the onion here you find
uh that we really have made a lot of
poor judgments when it comes to electing
our presidents and our vice presidents
secret service you know despite the
recent publicity
overall does do a good job
when they get a threat
they investigate and they put
the threats into one of three categories
class three is considered the most
serious where the person really has the
intent of carrying out an assassination
has the ability in that case
when the president visits that person's
hometown agents will visit him or her
and warn him to stay away from the
president warn him that he'll be watched
until the president leaves and he will
be watched
on the other hand a class one threat
is someone who just blurts out in a bar
i wish i could kill a president he's
drunk it turns out uh after
investigation there was no real intent
and uh most likely that person will not
be prosecuted because it is a federal
crime to
threaten the president
one
time
president george h.w
h.w bush
was out greeting people at the gate of
the white house
he liked to do that and schmooze agents
didn't like that they wanted to screen
them
but a few days later
a story appeared in the washington post
that
bush was doing this
and then a few days after that
agents noticed a
sort of a classic uh
lone assassin uh
individual someone who fits the profile
of of a lone assassin namely
someone who
is
smiling when everyone else is not or
vice versa everyone's smiling and he's
frowning uh everyone else is wearing
summer clothes he's wearing a win a
winter overcoat
and they patted him down and sure enough
he had a weapon he had a pistol and
most likely would have used him
one of the most
bizarre stories
in this book the first family detail
is when again george h.w bush was going
to enid oklahoma
when he was campaigning for reelection
and the secret service did their usual
advance work they talked to
local law enforcement to see if there
were any threats out there local law
enforcement said you know there's a
psychic in town who's been incredibly
reliable in the past and has actually
led us to the bodies of her of murder
victims
and she had said that she has
had this vision
that when bush comes to town he's going
to be assassinated by a sniper on an
overpass
well the agents were of course
embarrassed to take this seriously but
at the same time they did
and they went and interviewed this woman
and they said do you know anything more
about this she said yeah i know that the
limousines for the motorcade are already
at uh
in town they said you know where yeah
the air force base
can you show us they went out there she
pointed to a hanger and sure enough that
was where the limousines were there were
five hangers she pointed to the correct
one
but then she said that when bush comes
out of air force one the next morning
he's going to be wearing
a sport jacket and a sports shirt well
they thought that was nuts you know he
always wears a a suit
they did tell headquarters about it
uh but the next morning uh they went to
uh greet
uh bush as he came out of air force one
and sure enough he was wearing a
uh jacket a sport jacket and a sports
shirt and a shiver went down their
spines
and they decided to
divert the motorcade to an alternate
route which would not go under any
overpass
and of course
bush was safe he was never told about it
at the time he's
he's learned about it for the first time
in this book
but that is one of the more
bizarre stories that i reveal in this
book as well as just how agents do their
job
for example when
the president goes out of town he's
going to stay in a hotel agents will not
only
make sure that nobody else
is a guest on the floor where the
president stays but nobody else is a
guest even on the floor above and the
floor below
and they will
check out the suite where the
president's going to stay they'll
replace the tv with their own tv because
the tv could be a surveillance device
they'll get rid of the telephone of
course they'll look for bug bugs
um they've only found bugs in a few
cases where they were left over
uh in the hotel because some
actor or other celebrity had been there
and someone who was trying to bug them
uh they'll they'll uh search through the
carpets and the frames of pictures
to look for explosive device or devices
or detonating devices
uh and then they'll also check out
local hospitals
exit routes
safe houses such as a firehouse where
they might go go if there is an attack
they have
what they call expedient hoods which
they would put over the president in the
event of a chemical attack
so it is quite involved
however in the book i go into
a
culture within management which really
started uh in 2003 when the department
of homeland security took over the
secret service
of corner cutting laxness and an
attitude of we make do with less we're
the great
secret service we don't have to lock the
door of the white house
because we're so wonderful
and an arrogance you saw the arrogance
when when
julia pearson the secret service
director issued a statement saying that
when the
white house intruder gonzalez
entered the white house ran through most
of the white house with a knife he could
have had weapons of mass destruction he
could have had explosives that the
uniformed officers exercised
tremendous restraint
can you imagine that
here's this guy he could have blown up
the white house and and she's praising
uh the agents and the officers for
exercising restraint that shows the
arrogance of the secret service that
they would think there were such fools
that we would you know fall for this
uh baloney and uh and think that the
secret service had done a good job
at the same time the secret service lied
about it they said initially that the
gonzalez was stopped at the door that
was a lie he actually penetrated the
white house over
powered a female agent
why
uniformed officers didn't unleash dogs
on them initially uh obviously they were
simply not paying attention
why didn't they take him out with legal
lethal force by definition
he was a threat to the president
obama had just left but he could have
returned and therefore should have been
taken out i mean you simply cannot wait
until he actually enters the white house
with with uh
weapons uh with wmd with explosives to
find out if he really is a threat
and and so uh on top of that
the female officer you know was
overpowered uh
and uh it took a an agent who was off
duty to finally
take him down
uh
so um
another item in the book
which the secret the washington post
picked up on without crediting the book
is that uh in 2011
there were shots fired at the white
house
a female uniformed officer reported that
but her supervisor overruled her
pooh-poohed her said it was a you know
probably from a construction site
and she later said she was afraid to
push the point because she was afraid
she would be criticized by management
and this again goes to the culture of
the secret service management it's not
the agents as i said it's the management
that really
punishes agents for raising any
questions whatsoever and so you have
this cover-up mentality it's it's uh
it's uh
really a rotten culture
that
can only be changed by an outside
director such as bob mueller was when he
came in as
the new uh direct director of the fbi he
had been the head of the criminal
division
not that the fbi was in terrible shape
like the secret service but it needed to
be more focused on prevention of plots
before they happen and that's exactly
what mueller did uh and made it clear
that anybody any agent who had the
attitude of you know i'm going to make
an arrest put him in jail that's the end
of it is is going to be uh
left to
to work cases in butte montana
the idea is to
focus on
uh
individuals who may become assets who
will lead the fbi to more plots more
more sources and that's why we have
actually not had a successful foreign
terrorist attacks since 9 11. people
don't
tend to connect that with the fbi but
that is exactly why along with uh help
from the cia that we have not had a
successful attack every few months you
see
uh arrests by the fbi of terrorists and
that's the bottom line that they are
doing their job i want to
speaking of the fbi just briefly
touch on my previous book the secrets
the fbi which reveals
how the fbi
breaks into homes and offices to plan
bugging devices without getting caught
and shot as burglars this is something
that is employed on any major case
whether it's terrorism organized crime
political corruption
and
what the agents do is two weeks before
the break-in
they of course case the joint and
they've and they determine who goes in
who goes out who works there
on the night of the break break-in
the agents will watch at the homes of
those individuals to make sure they
don't go back into the premises it could
even be an embassy
and if they do
the agents will divert them they'll have
police officers stop them give them a
ticket
they'll even have a phone
a traffic accident they may even open a
fire hydrant in the area so nobody can
go back to the area
and they also will take a photo of any
dog that might be on the premises
and show that to a veterinarian who's on
contract to the fbi
and the
the
veterinarian will prescribe just the
right amount of tranquilizer to shoot
into the dog with a dark gun before as
they're breaking in because of course
they don't want any barking dogs
and at the end of the break-in they'll
give that dog another shot to wake him
up they'll bring their own dust into the
break-in in case they disturb any dust
on a coffee table or desk they'll
replace the dust with their own dust
let's say they want to put bugs and by
the way they actually showed me
i mean i got incredible cooperation bob
mueller actually approved this
cooperation
personally they actually showed me a
real bug which is about the size of a
postage stamp a little bit thicker
it will record for 20 hours or
transmit
as you wish
so let's say they want to put a bug in
an office building
they go to elevate elevator school to
learn how to control elevators and
they'll go in they'll take control of
one of the elevators they'll get on the
top of the roof of the elevator and then
in the middle of the night they'll get
out they'll put the bugs in the suite
they'll get back on the elevator and
then during the day they'll come out
wearing business suits and nobody is a
wiser
let's say they want to put a bug in a
home in the middle of the night
they will take a photo of the front of
the house
and then blow that up into a huge tarp
that they drape over the front of the
house
so that any bystander walking by on the
street in the middle of night looks at
the house and thinks that's the house
but actually behind that tarp the agents
work to defeat the alarms and defeat the
locks
and they put the bugs in they also have
a phony bush that opens up like an
umbrella and they'll walk
slowly with the bush in front of them
towards the
uh front of the house and then
they'll shield themselves with the bush
as they defeat the locks and the alarm
systems
uh a tremendous number of anecdotes many
of them funny in this book the secrets
of the fbi and just one
is when they were going to put bugs in a
mafia hangout in uh philadelphia
the agents uh determined that there was
a back door but they didn't want to go
in the back door because it could be
booby-trapped so they had to go on the
front door but the front door overlooked
an all-night bar
and the patrons you know could see the
agents trying to defeat the the locks
so the agents borrowed a city bus
and they drove in front of the
uh mafia hangout which was supposedly an
electronic store they got out they put
the hood of the
uh of the bus up
so it looked as if the bus had broken
down
they got out they defeated the locks the
patrons couldn't see them because they
were behind the bus the bus went around
the block as they were putting the bugs
in it came back but it went by a bus
stop and there were two patrons from the
bar
uh
waiting for the bus and the bus went
whizzing by them and they were furious
and they went running for the bus and as
soon as i stopped in front of the mafia
hangout
these two guys ran in drunk
and
at first the agents didn't realize that
they weren't with them because the
agents were from different offices or
they were with this
secret team which is called tactical
operations or tacops which is a team
that breaks into the uh
homes and offices and and i was able to
actually go out to see
the headquarters of this operation
and there's a photo of it in the book
the secrets of the fbi
uh the agents started taking off their
weapons and their walkie-talkies and
then these two guys started ringing to
get off ding ding let me off let me off
they were scared and the agent who was
driving said hey guys stop bothering me
i'm having enough trouble driving this
bus you know they tell me how to drive
this in 20 minutes
and then another agent got up and he had
a shotgun over his shoulder and then
they really started
bringing to get off ding ding ding let
me off and so finally the agent was
driving understood what was going on
let them out they went running down the
street and nobody ever heard from them
again
um
it comes to the
secret service
budget
which is only 1.6 billion dollars a year
and that includes not only protection of
the president vice president
almost 40 individuals all together
including white house staff
as well as well as
visiting heads of state the national
nominating conventions plus the secret
service investigates counterfeiting and
financial crimes
uh
the budget is ridiculous it's about the
size the the amount of of one stealth
bomber
and the secret service just sort of
creaks along
uh like a like a car without
an oil change and all the way all around
it's it's crumbling
they don't
in fact they've actually refused to
update their
devices at the white house for detecting
intruders to more sophisticated
technological devices that are available
now they've refused to update
devices for detecting weapons of mass
destruction
they've refused to put
devices in to detect gunshots and
we saw that when the
uh see the secret service didn't realize
until four days later that the white
house had been shut up in 2011. even the
d.c police have devices for detecting
gunshots
they're not keeping up to date with the
latest firearms the fbi has more
powerful weapons
they will
not allow its time for agents to
qualify for
firearms requalification or physical
fitness tests and they cover that up by
asking agents to fill out their own test
scores so there's dishonesty involved
which should never be tolerated in any
law enforcement agency
when members of congress go out to the
secret service training center which
i've been to with my wife pam who
contributes uh vivid descriptions uh in
my books she's a former washington post
reporter and she wrote the book
undercover washington which is about
spying in washington
uh and we saw how they train for example
when when driving to do the j-turn where
they go 180 degrees around uh
and they do uh and they have scenarios
where they where they uh detect
explosives when members of congress go
out there uh and they're showing these
scenarios they're presented as
spontaneous and isn't it wonderful that
the agents did their job well actually
secretly
when congress goes out there the secret
service
rehearses the scenarios beforehand so
everyone knows the answers again total
dishonesty and nothing
uh nothing is worse than any law
enforcement agency
and you know they also pad their
statistics they they will take credit
for
uh
some cases that local police
have uh
investigated and closed and then they go
out and make a copy of the report and
they call that an investigation and they
include that in their statistics i mean
it's just the most poorly managed
organization you can imagine
and
uh in my previous book in the
president's secret service i went into a
little bit of this
but much more in the new book
and one one of the more shocking
uh
examples of this corner cutting
is that under pressure from
white house staffs or political or
campaign staffs
the secret service will let people into
events without magnetometer or metal
detection screening it's just like
letting passengers into an airplane
without metal detection screening if
anybody did that they would be fired or
possibly prosecuted but secret service
will will cut corners in this way
because an event is about to start
there's still a line outside
mainly because the secret service hasn't
provided enough magnetometers and uh and
then they'll cave the secret service has
no business
caving um
any of these events could result in an
assassination you could have five
terrorists come in with grenades and yet
on a regular basis
the secret service will will engage in
this in this real negligence and this is
something that still has not been picked
up by the press
um
based on my previous book i i wrote in
the washington post in an op-ed
back in 2012 may 2 2012.
so far the biggest scandal in the
history of the secret service involves
agents hiring prostitutes in colombia
which is by the way a story that i broke
but the media have largely ignored a
much bigger scandal at the agency a
lacks management culture that condones
cutting corners directly endangering the
life of the president that was in 2012
and yet it wasn't until uh the intrusion
by gonzalez and uh the fact that a uh an
armed individual
uh who had not been screened was allowed
in an elevator with with uh the
president that finally finally president
obama uh obviously
demanded the resignation of the director
julia pearson but the previous director
mark sullivan also should have been
removed
should have been removed after the
salahis the party crashers entered the
white house state dinner even though
they were not on the guest list as well
as the third intruder carlos allen
another story that i broke
why would uniformed officers
ignore the fact that they were not on
the guest list ignore the fact that
they'd
not gone through a background check
one clue and and you can tell from the
spinelessness i'm talking about
but also one clue
is that when mary cheney dick cheney's
daughter was under protection
she would
try to get her
agents to take her friends to
restaurants as if they were taxi drivers
well they refused as they should they're
law enforcement officers they are to
protect uh individuals under certain
laws and and certainly not that doesn't
include taking uh
mary cheney's friends to restaurants but
she threw a fit
and got her detailed leader removed over
this so one message does that send to
the uniformed officers at the white
house gate who are confronted with this
glamorous couple it says hey if it turns
out that they were supposed to be on the
guest list and there was some error and
then the white house staff complains
we could be in trouble with our
management because our and our own
management would not back us
as was the case with mary cheney
and by the way anybody who who thinks
that this book is not apolitical i point
you to
republicans such as mary cheney who are
skewered in this book as well as
spiro agnew for having
a number of affairs going at once even
though he claimed to be for family
values that was his whole shtick
um as well as jenna bush who
evaded her agents all the time gave them
a hard time would even go through red
red lights trying to get through
trying to evade her agents just didn't
understand what security was all about
thought it was a big game um and uh
senator ted cruz you're gonna have to
buy the book to find out what i say
about senator ted cruz but i think it's
interesting
um
and so uh
then you ha
at that point uh president obama said he
has confidence in the secret service how
can anybody say they have confidence in
the secret service you know it's not
that uh he has to
come out publicly and criticize them he
can just be quiet but at the same time
look for replacement for mark sullivan
mark sullivan it turns out
uh
ordered this is one of the most shocking
revelations ordered agents
who were protecting president obama at
the white house including
when he lifted off in marine one to go
to
uh
camp david one weekend
uh especially uh looking out for snipers
uh that might try to take him out as
he's lifting off with his family
ordered these agents who were on what's
called the prowler team
to
instead of protecting the white house go
to southern maryland
to protect mark sullivan's own assistant
who had been harassed by a neighbor
this neighbor had appropriately called
the police the police were handling it
the secret service has absolutely no
legal authority any more than the fbi to
protect its own employees and yet mark
sullivan
saying ordering agents to keep this
secret uh told them to go and protect
his own assistant over a matter of
months
and then on top of that and that was
revealed by the washington post i had
the story back in 2012 but
books being what they are i hadn't
brought it out yet
but was not but what was not in the
washington post and is in this book
is that
the agents on top of all that retrieved
confidential law enforcement records
about this neighbor again not only a
violation of law but a violation of
criminal law to retrieve confidential
law enforcement records on anyone unless
you have a legal basis which they did
not have
so
not only
is this a shocking example of
dereliction of duty
by mark sullivan to protect the
president
not only a violation of criminal law
but it shows the culture and it shows
the
effect on the agents agents are there to
protect the president they'll take a
bullet for the president they are real
patriots and yet
they're being told by the director oh
it's not really important to protect the
president you know i'll just have my
assistant protected as a favor
now another example in the book
and this has not hit the press yeah
is that
when uh
the actor bradley cooper
i know you know who bradley cooper is
but i didn't know who he was so i'm
saying he's an actor
um
went to the white house correspondents
dinner
where obama spoke
a high-ranking secret service official
in new york
ordered agents at the washington hilton
to let
bradley cooper and his suv
into the secure area in front of the
hotel
where only secret service vehicles were
allowed and even they had to be screened
for explosives by dogs namely belgian
malwa dogs who
cost four thousand five five hundred
dollars each they're trained to uh sniff
out explosives and also to take down an
individual such as one running across
the white house lawn
and anybody could attach explosives to
the underside of a car i'm obviously i'm
not saying that bradley cooper is a
terrorist but anybody could have
attached uh explosives to the underside
of a car and that's why even secret
service vehicles have to be screened for
explosives and yet this
new york official in the secret service
apparently has some favor to
bradley cooper and his security people
to impress them perhaps he's looking for
a job once he gets out
tells them to just ignore the most basic
security procedures you can imagine
again the dismay of the agents who are
there to protect the president and
they're being told to ignore the most
basic security precautions
so that again
tells you the culture that has brought
us to this point
where we actually uh
have an intruder running into the white
house uh
the uh and an individual allowed in an
elevator period who has not been
screened regardless of whether the
individual has a gun you know by by
basic protocol you never let anybody in
the elevator with the president unless
it's someone who's been screened and and
is already known to the secret service
um
so that is where we stand today um i do
hope that uh
president obama chooses
a good
outside individual to head the secret
service i think
his
failure to replace
the direct the director uh right after
the salahi's which was
what six years ago it is a colossal uh
failure of of management judgment i
think also perhaps he
is very impressed by his own agents as
i'm sure he should be and so
uh he thinks well you know this
represents the secret service there's no
problem and yet it's his own life that
has been at stake and still is at stake
as well as the lives of his own family
so
that is where things stand i think that
obama is capable of of selecting a good
leader for the secret service as he did
with james comey he's the new fbi
director he's he's very admired by
agents he's doing a good job um you know
it is possible to get someone from the
outside who who can shake it up
change the culture is not beholden to
interest within the agency
but i'm telling you it's going to be
monumental task because
every where you look
there's corner cutting there's laxiness
there's a culture of spinelessness
and and it is solely and sorely in need
of reform
uh and i hope that uh
individuals reading this book
will will consider it to be a roadmap of
what needs to be done to reform the
secret service because it has dozens of
other examples of
this culture of corner cutting as well
as
the real story on our leaders and that's
something that we need to wake up to we
need to
pay attention to
character and track record and stop
fooling around with you know did they
make a gaffe in some debate and uh are
they nice on tv
um and that's the way we've been
choosing presidents and over over again
we're disappointed
uh and that is the
the most i think important message
in this book and i'd like to take your
questions
yes the first question uh mr kessler as
you explained that there is like a high
level of frustration among uh like uh
the secret service agents
yeah uh uh this is like as i've been uh
as fm just shoot from
like your briefing that's right um is
there uh like um
any initiatives from any congressional
committee maybe or any any other uh
organization to go ahead and conduct
uh such reforming for the for the agency
even though if it's gonna
step into the president's rule uh among
all of this
yeah is there a level of frustration you
can believe there is and and uh i
interviewed many uh current agents as
well as former agents
i was also able to
as i said get cooperation from the
secret service uh to to visit the
training center and the and the uh
command center but um
they are outraged the agents are just
outraged at this at this culture and yet
you know they feel that their their jobs
are at stake when when agents were
ordered to uh
protect the assistant of the director
mark sullivan they felt that they were
probably violating the law and yet they
felt that if they
if they
blew the whistle if they stood up for
for what was right they would be fired
um and uh that's how serious it is i
mean it's just uh a scandalous culture
the other part of the question was
will hearings and investigations uh
be useful and go into this
um you know i remember back after the
salahi's
did their thing uh crashing the state
dinner
there were hearings on the hill
and they you know gave the director a
hard time nothing changed absolutely
nothing changed if you
have any organization that's screwing up
let's say if microsoft or apple were
losing a lot of money what would you do
you'd bring in a new ceo
who would shake it up you wouldn't have
hearings you wouldn't have
investigations you wouldn't have reviews
um and that's exactly what's needed with
the secret service it's it's simple uh
but but
you know you get the right manager in
there
for example when bob mueller was uh
fbi director as soon as he came in
he was having uh brief briefings by top
fbi officials and one of the officials
who was over counterintelligence
started obfuscating and and misleading
about problems within her
division which involved a spy case in
los angeles
and muller
just removed her like that and boy that
sent a message right away you better be
honest you better be candid and you
better do your job and that made a huge
difference in the fbi that's what you
need with the secret service um a good
manager and um you know uh people say
well it should be women should it be mad
it's so unfortunate that we have to
think like that you know we have so many
women who are who are so capable of
running businesses
uh meg whitman comes to mind uh and
certainly uh within the government the
same uh as well as men and uh
it just needs to be someone who who who
knows what he or she is doing and that's
it's it's very very simple
yes um why don't you think that the uh
the fbi is so much better funded than
the secret service
the fbi
rightfully has been pushing to get more
funding
and has done a very good job of it
whereas the secret service
not only has not been pushing for more
funding because they could get it you
know if they went to obama and said hey
your life is at risk we're really
screwing up we better double the budget
which is what i think should happen um
boy you can be sure that money would be
provided my god 1.6 billion dollars is
ridiculous for uh for this agency um and
and congress would go along as well but
but as part of this screwed up culture
they have the attitude of we make do
with less and i you know in my book i
quote mark sullivan as actually saying
that we make do with less they're
actually proud to spend less money i
mean what are they thinking this is the
present united states we're talking
about if you have an assassination you
nullify democracy you know people
sort of
recoil when you use the word
assassination
because
it's so unthinkable and it sounds so
terrible but you know it's very very
possible in fact i quote
in the book and by the way two-thirds of
the book is on the record
one
individual who's not on the record who
says
uh that it's a miracle that there has
not already been an assassination
because of all this corner cutting and
you know even with the best security the
president is very
vulnerable uh and and and with the worse
security and now of course you know isil
terrorists are gonna realize that they
could they could overwhelm the white
house after what happened uh it's a
terrible situation you know another
uh difficulty that agents face besides
their screwed up management
is that
many presidents think they're immortal
and and and poo poo advice that they're
given by the secret service and that
goes back to
jfk jfk
refused to let agents ride on the rear
running board of his limousine they
wanted to have two agents on the rear
running board of his limousine in dallas
well if they had been there
the agents would have jumped on him as
soon as the first shot was fired which
was not fatal
and pushed him to the floor and saved
his life there's no question whatsoever
um and so really you know with all the
conspiracy theories and all the talk
about whether the secret service screwed
up in in the end i'm afraid it was the
president himself who who uh made it
possible uh
for for him to to lose his own life
abraham lincoln the same thing he was
even though the civil war was going on
he refused to have any security
finally just before his assassination he
agreed to have one d.c police officer
with him on the night of the
assassination this one d.c police
officer parker decided to go off and
have a drink at a local tavern so
lincoln was totally unprotected
and of course he was shot and killed
so secret service has so many so many
difficulties that they have to face
it's one of the most important agencies
in the federal government
um
and uh until now of course it has been
very secret
people ask me how did you get them to
talk usually i would waterboard them and
that worked pretty well
but i think that they they
understand
that i tell an honest story i have a
track record of writing about the fbi
the cia
uh and other uh sensitive
areas
um
and that uh i will tell it like it is
and for example with the fbi i say that
uh they've been doing a wonderful job
since 9 11 but on the other hand one of
my previous books
uh exposed william sessions the fbi
director at the time for engaging in
personal abuses having the fbi pay for a
fence around his home that had no
security purpose
taking personal trips on the fbi plane
quite a few other
infractions even even letting his wife
alice into uh fbi headquarters even
though she didn't have a
top secret clearance
she would be given
a pass so she could get in and that book
led to his dismissal as fbi director and
so if
if agents you know really really are
dedicated to the truth they understand
that i'm
going to tell the truth as well
um also i've been told that i listen
very well and that seems awfully
simplistic and doesn't take a lot of
skill but
i did a book on palm beach i call that
my midlife crisis i wanted to drink more
champagne and go to parties with my wife
pam and
it is a secret society there in palm
beach uh which i was able to penetrate
and one of the people there said you
know nobody here listens to anybody you
listen and uh that's perhaps part of why
i have been able to tell these stories
in these books
yes you have some good stories in there
on kind of a lighter note you talked
about i think the secret service working
with a psychic
was it the george bush threat i think it
was can you talk about that i i did talk
about that just now oh the fact that uh
the secret service service actually
listened to a psychic and and uh it is
one of the more amazing stories in the
book uh
and um
i'm glad you pointed that out
any other questions
all right well thank you so much for
coming and i appreciate your questions
[Applause]
here's some of the latest news about the
publishing